my
Oh
flighty to high level things apart
well come on Doug let's not make a bob
sisters I think one of the people on
Facebook told us about this shisha bar
we came here to just give it a bit of
leaflets my brother Jimmy can you
explain what happened
okay what does it look like looks like a
lounge from yeah but does it look open
to you at me please
it's closed at least it as well as
expecting it was tan so basically
schools that have knowledge today
brothers and sisters I think actually
made a specific law so the shisha lodge
is closed down low discreet distinction
man
we are came across an association was
the corner the same on the side of a
tree road I came across a couple of few
sisters and a few brothers
I just talked to him in general I'm the
right like you know when we talk about
its kind of stuff and I don't like to
feel like we're the good guys and in the
back you get it I've just given
understand sister love you know which
they baptize you know etc etc I know
they took it it was really done they're
really not happy they were okay over
there funky hockey thanks for sharing
with us forget it you know they were
acceptant in a way you can try the same
so we're going to do is we're not here
to be Haram police and I'll go there or
were the good guys are the bad guys
that's not our objective and Abe and you
know that's a bit of arrogant thing to
do even if it was to do that may Allah
protect us from that we're here to just
give advice to the brothers and sisters
with these cars in sha allah as a
benefit to them so maybe they might be
reminded cuz i didn t a lot of people
think she tried said trial it's not a
big deal but these kind of environments
is the leading cause for major sins that
Xena drugs etc etc so today hamdullah
we're going to walk up and down give
some leaflets talk to some brothers and
sisters in java and inshallah everyone
will be benefited I'll keep you updated
really soon
haha relay even heaven already d'Italia
given up there quickly a lot more than
rodeo quickly confine in yet quick quick
quick I'm looking out cause they're like
no speak louder basically Smith it's a
bit saddening are you seeing he would is
our horror gone
yeah there's no didn't even part in word
but a part in enough will be a sin in it
just going to head to the other side of
Israel road because there's a couple of
shisha bar there and I will kit and
we'll keep you updated on Haley a bus
yelling man Tel Aviv
Bailey could end up in alumni
turn to the dairy compiler banana how
come my user Philippa in Berlin in
Sarnia dan welcome back Amanda sable at
the hospital have Naaman and the soft
now there's enough labor so we mean open
hey
ooh grumbling sisters how you guys do an
age Mubarak along Muhammad minimum
income brothers and sisters I'm asking
you guys sincerely for the sake of Allah
just lend me your ear for about three to
five minutes when a person is about to
die what he says what she says just
before she dies is his most important
wish so the Prophet SAW Allah while he
was selling he's about to die he's about
to leave this world and the only thing
he's telling us is like as if to say the
only thing I want you to know is the
prayer the prayer the five daily prayer
don't miss it the Prophet was sitting
with his companions and he became very
sad he said I yearn he said I yearn to
meet my brothers and I yearn to meet my
sisters Bolero do one look to the
Prophet and he said yo Rasul Allah your
brothers and your sisters are here we
and the Prophet looked at all of his
companions he looked at Abu Bakr bus man
I need the greatest people to walk the
face of this earth from Bassam MA
and he said you are not my compat you
are not my brothers you're my companions
he said my brothers my brothers and my
sisters are those who come they will
believe in me and they have not seen me
you are my lord the most high and I
promise you on that day everyone will
turn their back on you but Allah will
suffice you so boo come we're gonna make
the iodine in sha allah and i urge you
guys to pray with us the level not your
toes
still are
mmm
manikyam
we
entirely
okay show these guys so these guys
wanted to leave early but they had to
come back why can't come back so that
morality why have to come back
so basically under we finish this Rock
one now regular took my keys and left
earlier and look stayed is to be able to
be more dour they say nobody chose it
okay so they left and I was a good you
can se put my keys
and then they had to come grab the
trophy so I mean ask me how did it go
I'm the Lowe's could provide somewhere
people reason why a to rise with broken
will go and do this specifically we
don't want to look down on anyone we
don't want say hey we're the good guys
you're the bad guys we just sincere
advice to Robin system that's about it
my career tomorrow so we shall organizes
your today's blog is done so that more
important
he's by the event funny
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
care to brothers and sisters and dear
friends we've just concluded our day at
some of our food you know it's been a
tiring day hamdullah got some food now
Brahman since I just wanted to share
something with you guys as you know I
made it a bit of lack of vlog type kind
of thing so you guys can see you know
the building up procedure to our mission
that we did the towel day that we had
them see a day and we do this every day
last year is well the reason why we do
this is Bravo sisters because we know
there's a little youth out there who in
Ramadan may Allah bless them me Allah
grant them John are they trying their
best they Prince Allah waking up for
Fajr whatever it may be I'm doing like
they do really good but when it comes to
eat unfortunately a lot of people they
have this misconception but this thought
or thinking okay we've done it now is
Eid we have to party you don't have to
pass you get I'm trying to say you can
you can do it in the best way possible
for example spending it in a bad way
instead of being out in shisha bars
nightclubs wherever it may be gee I'm
trying to say now brothers and sisters
what we need to understand it's like for
example when it comes to shisha
yeah now as far as we know is Haram you
know because I didn't they whatever
harms your body is Haram and it's been
proven by scientists that she shot is
more harmful to your body than
cigarettes so we know that is Haram but
even that you can say okay yeah but I
just have a habit I just go to shisha
bars but what you need to understand is
my dear sister my brother is that when
you go to these environments where
there's music where there's shisha where
there's free mixing where there's
alcohol where there's all these kind of
madness is some people some of them
shisha bar saw Billy dancing it's like a
nightclub dude I'm trying to say except
you don't have a DJ you know now knowing
that when you go to these environments
what you need to understand is you might
think okay smoking shisha is a minus in
yeah or music is a minus in or for
example free mixing is a minus in for
example I'm saying yeah even though that
for at any you need to understand is
that the one that you're sinning against
nothing is minor that's little put that
to a side but what you forget is that
these minor sins could be the reason why
major sins are committed such as
drinking alcohol doing drugs committing
zina
now when Alice Montano says in the
do not come near zina what does he mean
by that my dear brothers and sister is
that if I know zina is here right I am
NOT going to say let me go just a bit
around it no no I will say I will go
round the block I don't even want to go
next to it why because of the temptation
of falling to it so that's why when you
go to an environment is free mixing
music girls guys everything's going
around egg somebody's number this time
always just want marriage I'm serious my
intentions are right one thing leads on
to another and before you know it like
the messages that we get day-in day-out
from brothers and sisters I've committed
sinner so what is the best thing to do
is to avoid these places well I just try
your best to avoid these places and like
I said before we've seen many problems
since you've done many beneficial stuff
why ruin that one line why ruin that by
going out there now when we went out
there the reason why we do it is some
people might look and say you know what
our Haram police why you guys are
involved going invading people's privacy
this that look well lie he the first
thing as my team when when I talk to
them you know is that look at keys this
is what I told them brothers we are not
here as haram police you know we're not
here to like hey we're the good guys
we're the good ones
eh we're pious you know and you guys are
the bad guys every person that I gave a
leaflet to or we had a conversation with
the first thing that I say to them is my
dear sister my dear brother
what like just because I'm giving you
this leaflet or this card on this
reminder in no way does it mean that I'm
better than you because indeed you might
have a sincere deed and a pure intention
that you do that deed with which maybe
more detail other than anything that I'm
doing so the thing that I remind them is
that because I don't want to be arrogant
I don't want to be feeling yeah I'm the
good guy but like us as a team as a team
online we hate that we don't want to be
arrogant and we're the good guys I don't
we don't want this behavior and then
that's the reason why we just advise
them and say my dear brother my dear
sister you like my own brother
I just want to advise you give you this
car - I know you can benefit and
hamdulillah a lot of people - the
leaflets and a lot of people benefited
out of it Doogie I'm trying to say so to
be honest to wrap it up brothers and
sisters what like that's about it from
me don't cause your own hands
be your own destruction rely this
lifestyle whatever it may be
hamdulillah we didn't see many sisters
out and about a lot of brothers out
unfortunately but what like this
lifestyle never would have bring
happiness Allah says in the Quran indeed
with my remembrance two hearts find
peace if you forget about me you will
have a depressed life so brothers and
sisters let's understand the other swans
Allah wants the best for you you know
Alice wanted doesn't want to punish you
like Allah says in the Quran what would
like it out punishing you what am I
going to get what like he's saying it
for that we're just here to give a
reminder and a benefit and an advice and
that's what we've done with the team
with Imran as you saw for yourself
they always wanted a grant every student
guys in China and please forgive me if
I've come across arrogant in any way or
we're being Haram police one light
that's not what we all just want the
best for our brothers and sisters that's
about it from me me I was not to grant
every single one of you guys gender once
more time and please subscribe and share
this video
assalamualaikum warahmatullah better
here